hydro québec annonce que sa nouvelle
filiale îlots s'associer à la compagnie
québécoise tels pro dans le
développement de la domotique
la coentreprise va développer des
produits connectés comme des thermostats
intelligents et autres produits
connectés les équipements seront
fabriqués à shawinigan hydro québec
s'attend à ce que îlots contribuer à
l'économie d'électricité ce qui
permettrait d'augmenter ses exportations
sébastien fournier et le pdg d' îlots
bonsoir que fait il aux îlots en fait ça
fait soixante quinze ans qui drew
participent à la production au transport
et à la distribution d'électricité îlots
s'inscrit dans la suite logique va
offrir des produits et des services à
valeur ajoutée où on va aller l'autre
côté du content donc on va par exemple
offrir des produits services pour la
maison connectée comme ça exactement
comme ceux thermostats intelligents qui
est fabriqué par ce tempo exact et par
îlot éventuellement oui exactement donc
c'est thermostat de l'offre fera partie
de la gamme de produits qu'on va offrir
la kz2 la maison connectée il l'aurait
aussi présent dans les immeubles
connectés donc les institutionnels ou
commerciaux
on va participer aussi à des projets et
des produits on va offrir des produits
des services du côté du stockage de
l'énergie donc on peut penser à des
batteries tant du côté industriel
commercial que résidentiel
l'autoproduction par panneaux solaires
ou encore des bornes bi directionnelle
pour recharger son véhicule
donc on est vraiment dans une nouvelle
phase d'utilisation de l'élite de
l'électricité et de l'économie
d'électricité absolument donc le le le
but annoncé c'est vraiment de rendre ces
technologies le au service de la
clientèle de l'utilisateur et utilement
d'avoir des ristournes qui permettront à
l'utilisateur de baisser sa facture
d'électricité de mieux utiliser
l'électricité pour hydro-québec kg hl
avantage c'est vraiment de pouvoir plus
finement gérer la distribution de
l'électricité dans le réseau et donc
l'ultime en diminuer les investissements
qu'on fait dans le réseau qui
aujourd'hui sont à hauteur de 2 puis 3
milliards de dollars par an est de
dégager donc de l'énergie pour en
exporter davantage aliments absolument
dans des marchés voisins mais est ce que
ces petits appareils l'avons mieux nous
connaître
est ce que ce sont des appareils qui
vont aller chercher beaucoup plus de
données sur notre consommation et mieux
connaître les consommateurs
en fait c'est des produits qui sont
connectés là les utilisateurs le
contrôle total de cette technologie là
évidemment pour permettre on va voir par
exemple à l'intérieur de l'application
qui va permettre de contrôler ces objets
là on va accompagner le client dans son
dans sa consommation d'électricité ont
valu suggéré par exemple de mieux
program is et ses horaires de changer
certains comportements mais à tout
moment le l'usager le client et peut
plus se retirer du programme
mouais est-ce que c'est très différent
au fait en quoi c'est différent de
google est par exemple ou deux hommes
quittent d'apple de mise à notamment il
existe là ces produits là déjà
oui sauf que on sincère
vraiment du côté de l'énergie donc par
exemple je veux donner un exemple la
raison pour laquelle on a fait un
partenariat bestel poussé pour contrôler
ou avoir une influence sur le
développement qu'on va faire de ces
technologies la de sur le logiciel sur
l'évolution que ça va prendre
et par exemple on peut ajouter des
algorithmes à l'intérieur même d'un
thermostat qui va et des réseaux algérie
des reprises après pente par exemple
donc pourquoi que toutes les maisons
puissent reprendre en même temps le
chauffage on va pouvoir venir gérer plus
intelligemment et ultime en faire des
économies sur l'infrastructure du réseau
c'est pour qui et c'est pourquoi c'est
pour tout le monde et c'est pour très
bientôt donc on va avoir un lancement
commercial grand public à l'été automne
la technologie est prête donc on était
en période de rodage le pour l'instant
il ya déjà des projets pilotes
il ya des annonces qui s'en viennent
bientôt il ya ce lundi un projet pilote
concernant la tarification dynamique est
ce qu'un ennemi avec ça non ces deux
deux choses complètement différent nous
aussi on est dans une offre un service
vraiment où les gens vont voir peu sont
accompagnés dans la gestion de leur
consommation d'énergie la tarification
dynamique elle il doit y avoir une
intervention là de la part du client
donc s'il ya vraiment un accompagnement
de l'équipement est installé le chéquier
les panneaux solaires c'est pour quand
on le voit dans nos dans nos études
qu'on n'est pas encore la parité pour le
retour sur l'investissement mais on voit
qu'ils accourent échéance elle sera donc
on veut s'assurer qu'il vous sera prêt
puis on a déjà le set 7 800 clients chez
hydro-québec qui produisent déjà leur
énergie avec les panneaux saint louis et
jusqu'à quand jusqu'à combien on pense
qu'on peut aller chercher des économies
d'énergie est ce que vous avez identifié
où est donc on a des objectifs à terme
d'aller chercher entre 800 et 1500
mégawatts
oui et ça ça va nous coûter convient moi
si je veux seulement les matins ça me
coûte combien ça va être avantageusement
offert par île où on est encore en train
de finaliser nous nos offres
commerciales ils seront lancés l'été
prochain mais je pense que ce qu'on va
offrir c'est vraiment des ristournes
donc et donc si les gens veulent
participer par exemple à des événements
de de pointe hivernale en grand un grand
froid
il va y avoir des retours le qui seront
faits de façon monétaire ou sur les
factures donc qu'on veut réduire par
après oui oui ok mais la machine le
service d'une installation le technicien
qui va venir à la maison on fera payer
pour ça qu une partie qui sera payé mais
évidemment la note dans le modèle la
faille
il ya un effort qui fait de la part du
loup on va venir accompagner le client
de ce côté là aussi très intéressant
monsieur fourni on va reparler
certainement merci beaucoup merci